Olá
[Música]
eu sou Jadir Eu sou uma mulher que foi
criada por mãe e vó minha vó teve 11
filhos
e1976 deixou uma relação abusiva Minas
Gerais e daí para o Paraná os cinco
filhos pequenos a mais nova a minha mãe
a caçula linda 18 anos ela engravidou de
mim eu fui criada como uma boneca
estudar em colégio particular fiz
informática inglês e a mãe abraçou
maternidade com aquela costura super
professora essa menina vai dar certo
e também imagina só lá em 1982
tira Já começou o Padre Cícero me
batizar eu fui batizada dele e por aí
vai
apresentação da Escola crises de asma pé
quebrado
algo
recentemente Eu e meu esposo
conversávamos sobre uma amiga e se
separou com filhos pequenos Pires ou
algo mais ou menos assim
só como foi difícil para sua mãe para
sua avó eu parei e pela primeira vez eu
senti porque tem então eu pensava o
seguinte a foi difícil para minha mãe me
criar sozinha passando uma pronta é
difícil uma entrevista de emprego é
difícil mas pela primeira vez eu senti e
eu falei
muito difícil para minha mãe da minha
avó mas nunca reclamou eunuco
é o caso difícil sai da boca da minha
mãe o da minha vó
na vida está leve para você
provavelmente em algum figurinha da
Barra que permite olhar e reconhecer vai
estar vida está pesada para você
provavelmente é você que tá segurando a
barra para alguém Peça ajuda parece
Óbvio mas eu demorei 38 anos para sentir
como foi difícil para minha mãe para
minha avó
Oi tudo bem eu não estudei minha mãe
cima Afinal filha de mãe solteira o que
que vai ser dessa menina não vai ser
nada da minha vida logo bastarda foi
algo com o mundo eu vi
eu fui para a faculdade conseguiu
estágio nos em
estava indo para o trabalho
a vizinha
6 horas da manhã o seu já está claro mas
aquele dia não eu só estava 5 a rua
deserta e eu fui assaltado
é aquela menina aquela princesa nunca
apanhado eu fui feita por trás
jogada no mato isolado na cara e apagada
com estrangulamento
e eu me recordo de quando apagada acha
que ele tivesse morrido e conversar
comigo mesmo
e o que vai ser da minha mãe quando ela
me encontrasse Deus não permita que isso
aconteça
na sequência
hoje eu vim a respiração e como vocês
podem ver o milagre acontecer
e hoje estou aqui contando da casa com
toda essa história para você
essa é a primeira vez que eu falo
publicamente e dessa Fatalidade que
marcou a minha história e por que eu não
falei nunca antes tem coisas que não são
ditas mas são apreendido
o meu aprendi a nunca usar os momentos
tristes aconteceram na minha vida como
muleta
é o mesmo me fazer de difícil mas se eu
fosse
ah e hoje
e quando eu paro de olho para trás eu
percebo
e eu aprendi a me fortalecer e eu
aprendi isso as mulheres camisões hoje
eu tenho clareza onde tem algo normal
diferençado que eu contei da minha avó
no início minha avó os meus sua casa
fazendo cocada para fora com ajuda dos
seus filhos e quando se dividir em dois
serviços públicos estados e municípios
como zeladora e merendeiras ela era
muito trabalhadeira abusada esse termo
não para ela Claro
e após ser internada por ser vítima de
um derrame Ela voltou para casa mas
nunca mais para o trabalho
aqui do lado esquerdo paralisado e tive
que aprender a fazer tudo pela mão
direita e calo ela era Canhoto eu me
acorda de que tinha olhar admirada Como
atingir o fogão ela não pedir ajuda ela
cuidava a caixa de fósforo entre seu
quadril e o fogão estava tudo com a
única vão
70 nasce mulher gigante
bom e talvez
tudo sobre sim não atingir com as
mulheres a história Talvez seja aqui
hoje não tem importância e da
possibilidade de fortalecer o poder
pessoal de uma mulher e também controle
das minhas próprias coisas e descoberta
e é por ela
por tudo que eu desisti a minha esposa
é porque eu estou aqui hoje conteúdo
sobre a mulher que eu sou e conseguia a
partir de quinta coisa desde pequena que
los 5 em processo
é uma coisa importante é que hoje eu
trabalho com mulher eu percebi que algo
muito comum e gritou delas a minha vó a
minha mãe e que eu percebo também na
minha história
e o que ficam com chave e
fortalecimento emocional e eu chamo viu
é o primeiro pe é a firme são não seja
tão crítica com você
um socorro que pai permita-se
e talvez essa sobrecarga toda com seus
múltiplos só tem não sei não seja de ser
agenda cheia de mão mas sim de menino
menos coisas que fortalece a
E isso não é egoísmo isso é punição de
olhar para se realizar
e você pode mesmo que todo mundo de que
se não você pode
o segundo sim é a proteção Você é a
única que sabe o filme em se
proteger na casa que eu nasci lá em
Campo Mourão ela tinha uma cerquinha de
madeira essa seca ela permite que você
conseguiu olhar do outro lado você não
precisa construir muros altos mas também
não deixa sua morada sem proteção
e coloca a cerquinha de madeira Mas com
físico isso é responsabilidade sua
o terceiro Sim
faço sim
você é muito mais forte do que imagina
obter ao quando você precisa essa força
emocional vem
Você precisa olhar para sua história não
para mudar a si mesmo mas para descobrir
momentos for eles vão te ajudar para
fazer as escolhas
e o mais difícil e verdadeiramente
potência
ativa cereais e citando notícia você
mesmo por um lado tão potente como todos
os outros e por outros são celular com
seus poderes únicos
e me falando em verdade essa é a minha
verdade eu cheguei de surpresa e uma
família liderada por mulher
Ah mas eu não estou
segunda e desenhar o número de famílias
chefiadas por mulheres passou De 28,9
Milhões em 2011 mais de 5,5 milhões de
crianças estavam sem o nome do
progenitor na sua certidão de nascimento
um número gigante de mulheres que a sua
responsabilidade pessoa mas não
unicamente sua alguém seja por isso que
pesquisas recentes
apontam maior prevalência de ansiedade
estresse depressão na população feminina
principalmente na academia além do que
não pode ser medido mas também sentido o
preconceito e talvez você tem essas
coisas do passado mas não ainda hoje
2021 eu não escuto pessoas mulheres
usando muito inteiras como algo negativo
aqui entre nós' mãe é mãe não é estado
civil mãe casada mãe divorciada mãe
viúva mãe solteira mãe é mãe não é
estado civil mãe é ruim e.
é mas antes de ser mãe ela é mulher
mulher quiser era mulher do carro preto
cria mulheres de batalha que Luca
o
principalmente a mulher que deixa sua
mãe
a marca não somente físico mas a marca
emocional
e você pode até 12 me acordar não se
lembrar Mas provavelmente você fica uma
mulher à frente da sua educação os em
casa mamãe babá
avó tinha irmã seja na escola no
Professor uma Educadora uma auxiliar
milha no Coração
parte dela está dentro de você não
apareceu nada faz que você conheceu se
você entendeu não como elas foram Mas
como você
em Julho 2018 cartão enjoo amor mas
principalmente em sua força de uma
mulher
a força física mas a força da aula o
poder de uma mulher é o Sesi todas as
gerações é uma eternidade é o que me
pediu e passarinho estar se vier depois
a circunferência disco traz a
possibilidade da construção de um mundo
emocionalmente fortes
isso é um sonho
antigo você pode ajudar a transformar em
perigosos como
fortalize uma mulher e você fortalecerá
se tudo uma geração